[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits on link and I'm
red this week at the round table of dim
lighting we are exploring our polar
opposite weekend we went to each pole
well of the earth what we we both went
on an adventure
yeah and the adventures couldn't have
been more different true and you know
what we're both wearing coordinated
adventure outfits today we're both
wearing camo yeah what can I got camo
sweats
I got a camo sweat on the inside right
can't with a jacket over Elsa and you've
got a black butt shirt with a camo you
had on the outside polar opposite but
the same lightning bolt I do not have a
lightning bolt I win you've probably
paid for two more dollars no this is it
just man this isn't just the fact that
we've got camo on is that we've all got
camo sweats on yeah that's different
we're vibing that's better
if you don't have camo get the hell out
of here Jenna I think that jasmine I
think Jacobs could be camo camo if you
were to go inside like a cave where
there was like paintings and then Jenna
could be campaigning sure if she went
into like a denim factory she could Pepi
camo and then felt like okay you're
wearing mercy yes so we we went on these
adventures I went on a camping adventure
that I would love to tell you about and
what you you went on an adventure how
would you describe it as a polar
opposite
it wasn't outdoors it was very very
indoors but tell the people I purchased
a VR headset you know what I actually
did I actually traveled the world but I
never got out of my underwear and I am
Oh buddy I'm excited about this now I
brought it with me I have it you have
put it on your head and my head at some
point what and what is it what's it
called is the oculus quest which is the
standalone not a sponsor standalone
oculus headset now we've played with the
oculus
rift on geom more I guess before but
that's the one that has to be hooked up
to a I got some sort of PC or whatever
and every time they hooked me up to that
thing on good mythical more it's just to
scare the crap out of me yeah and what
and you know what I'll talk more about
that about how I feel like my experience
differed from my previous experience
with VR and also I need a positive VR
exist one oh I don't know if I'm gonna
give you that but I'm not gonna give you
any wires that's one positive I'm gonna
just give you no wires it's all right
here it's just all one thing and I think
I change my life and change my family's
life so I'll talk about that but I you
know it's I woke up this morning the
reason why I put on camo is because it's
finally getting at least cooler here you
know if I get up early to go to the gym
camo cool right it's not to make you
coolers to make you not be seen well do
I need to examine wet though like
wearing wearing a layer of sweats well
you don't have own sweat you have on
sweats and a jacket which by the way we
went out on a double date the other
night with our wives and you know it had
been a little bit cooler than it has
been it was like 66 degrees Luke shows
up at my house he has on his shirt a
sweater and then a jacket over the
sweater oh yeah what and what is wrong
with and I got my bandana in my in my
jacket pocket in case I need to really
get my neck warm I know you've gotten
down to 63 degrees we went down to a
place called Italy where it's all these
different markets and places that it's
all Italian food and Kristi and I love
Italian food and you and Christie love
novelty foods and they and you had been
you'd scope this place out you told her
about it in passing and then she never
forgot about it she's like we got to go
to this place and I thought since it was
I mean I thought it was on the west side
and I'm like whoa once you go once you
leave the valley is they liable to get
cold over there
ocean breeze I got to be prepped man
well I could have left her in the car I
could have left the sweater and though
it was hot I mean you could have gone to
like Oregon
the way that you addressed I just it you
know I it just felt I like felt
inappropriate but I I'm ready for it to
get cold man cuz I'm gearing up for it
you know it's like speaking of gearing
up you know it's the middle October oh
we're about to do the bleak Crete
conference we got some stuff coming up
at least we're traveling to places
I mean Boston is it cold this is my
slide promotion of bleak Creek
conversations in the midst of
conversation yeah I mean it's gonna be
cold in Boston New York City Chicago I
don't think it's gonna be cold in Dallas
or winston-salem and then we're gonna be
back in Los Angeles yeah it's kind of
fell apart there as we moved into a
warmer region but yes those are the
Bleak Creek conversations we'll be
talking about the book you get a book
just by getting a ticket and we're gonna
premiere the documentary there that we
shot in Buies Creek and the Los Angeles
Show is going to feature all your
favorite mythical crew members if you
want to glad-hand some of them when
you're coming out to Dallas where we're
your Halloween cost I'm only using the
term glad-hand because I know that is
you like using the word so I just was
trying to throw you a bone now that you
started using I don't even think I use
it and no but I'm just I I think fall
like the precipice of Falls my favorite
time of year just cuz I love jackets ya
know and I like layers man well I've
noticed both of these I love it and
that's what's gonna make the bleep Creek
conversations most special is my layers
how many layers you're gonna bring on
stage might be three before maybe we've
also got the rhett and Link live for
more shows coming up in November if you
want to see it this is this guy's we're
tired of traveling you know what we're
gonna and now that I got this VR headset
I'm not gonna leave my home so in 2020
you're gonna get a chance to see us and
so if you want to see us come to one of
these shows Rhett link live.com so to
get into my camping excursion we we did
two nights camping in Sequoia National
Forest you know things have just gotten
so big
for us over the years we used to go
camping we used to go off-road he used
to do things with it and a lot of times
with our friend Nick and so Nick Nick
texted me and he was like hey Alice and
his wife's out of town he's taking his
girls camping and they're they're pretty
young I'm not I'm not good at estimating
ages how old are they they're probably
five and seven maybe eight ten six seven
and four yeah because
Lando's only nine and I you know I we
only had this one weekend but it kind of
worked out perfect that it was open I
mean when your kids get to be 16 and 14
and 15 like Locke is they start making
all these plans and they don't even tell
you hey I need you to take me to
so-and-so or I'm doing so and so or all
my friends are coming over and it's like
my weekend is just planned because I
just have to be around to make sure they
don't do something stupid right but long
behold Guardian this week Guardian this
weekend
it wasn't anything and I really wanted
to go camping I really wanted I was
pining to take them camping that's good
I felt sure they wouldn't be up for it
but I was like hey you want to go
camping I got that look in their face
they get whenever I mentioned the word
camping hiking or just anything
involving activity outdoors or not not a
screen but then I said with Nick's girls
Avonlea and Aria and they all lit up and
they're like yeah and I was like woah
this is great yeah let's do this
so we went we went we went camping with
them and on our way in one main thing
happened that I want to tell you about
but just as the preamble of course all
over the state of California they've got
these fire towers that have been built
as like lookout locations from like high
vantage points in mountains all over I'm
sure this is not limited to California
but it's very important here especially
with
with the fires and whatnot and you know
you stand up on this really tall tower
and you look out to see if there's a
sign of a fire and it's it's kind of
like the opposite of Lord of the Rings
where somebody would light a fire and
then oh you could see it for the
farthest mountaintop and then you would
like your fire and then the next
mountaintop and at the horizon would see
it and it was a milling so severe it was
a very efficient long-distance
signalling system they have a signalling
system for when they see fire because
the fire needs to go out I'm drawing a
comparison but it's probably way
different maybe the opposite they don't
use them that much anymore so it turns
out Nick had this idea to go see a few
of them and we on the way in we went to
the first one you know I wonder why that
is though I think because of helicopters
in different ways that they surveil
drones perhaps I can't say but I do know
that they don't use many of the fire
towers anymore ago some of them have
been burned by fires yep you know what
that is sad it makes sense yeah it's
made out of flammable material well you
put a tower in a place that there might
be fires eventually it's gonna burn down
well that's the spirit so we get to this
tower and there's a car park there
because someone has rented the fire
tower to camp in it how freaking cool is
is that sounds like some thought begin
to so we look up there I mean this thing
is freaking tall man I mean how many
feet oh gosh you are you just trying to
make me look stupid no just give me an
estimate
well I'm 6 feet tall oh gosh that's not
a good place to stay yeah I can't I a
tower and know how tall it is well is
30,000 35 feet or is it a hundred feet
tall it's 35 feet tall so that it's just
tall is like jumping off the cliff at
like Acapulco yeah it might be a little
taller than that I don't think it's
gotta be talked about 35 feet well I'll
show them a picture in the video vert
how many steps did you go up to get to
it I didn't count the steps because the
girls of lights of stairs did you go it
was one really straight flight a long
ways up
what the never there was no switchback
no no switchbacks he's straight up that
very steep - and they were weird they
were like poured concrete steps very
very steep we were able to go up there
because the two women who were camping
up there right when I got there Nick was
like hey can we come up they were like
ah sure so we go up there two women and
a dog up there we start looking around
this place is surrounded like a sitcom
it surrounded by glass just filing away
ideas over here you have to go on the
website exactly six months in advance of
when you want to book this place and
like it's it's like you got to be on
it's like getting tired amande
it's like getting tickets to see Billy
eyelash you know you got to be all over
it right oh my gosh it's sell it out
mm-hmm and that's how it is with a lot
easier places but it's pretty cool it's
very windy up there of course a great
view you know you're gonna get a good
view in a fire towel you're above the
trees right but you above everything
you're on a mountain to on a mountaintop
but then on a tower top that's why this
is at least seventy five feet in the air
it doesn't have to be a that makes more
sense I've been picturing like a long
stretch of trees and then just like a
giant tower that's looking over them but
yeah makes sense it's on a mountain you
got to be careful coming down and if you
got to use the bathroom it's a long way
to go down to get to that outhouse down
there Oh yours no like to burning out
there than up and they had a pulley
system to pull up all that crap well
surely you can just pee off the side so
that was pretty cool I mean we just
camped on the ground and then we go to
the trail of a hundred giants where they
don't have 100 sequoia trees but there's
a lot of sequoia trees growing you and I
went there with Mike mm probably seven
years ago five five years ago and it's
it's a very accessible path if you're if
you're thinking about going to in that
area I definitely recommend going to the
trail of a hundred Giants because you
get to see all these sequoia trees up
close and even if you're not great at
hiking it's right off the road
right you may remember when we went that
a double Sequoia grouping had fallen
like theirs
to sequoias that groove basically right
beside each other and I mean these are
the largest living things on the planet
by mass like more massive than a than a
blue whale the sequoia trees so and
pictures don't do it justice but it is a
it's amazing just to be there I mean
seeing the redwoods is awesome redwoods
are taller but sequoias are fatter or
fatter bigger around and stumpy but
still freakin huge and tall you may
remember that two of them fell at once
what and what across a pass I'm gonna
call it one on there is another one
there is a YouTube video during they
don't fall very off there in the winter
of of some falling of of one being
caught falling which is crazy I mean if
if one of the largest things on the
planet is falling and you're there for
it well not just that I'm gonna pull out
your phone and record the fact I mean
they're what they're what are you a
freaking war journalist they're like a
thousand years old or something so the
chances of you catching it falling I
mean it's just a very very slim chance
but I guess people are always there
walking around well not in the wind not
when it's like really snowed in they
tend to fall went but under the weight
of the snow but when we went in the
summertime they had started to rebuild
the path that the Sequoia had fallen
across so that now you could and we
climbed on it they leave Italy of course
they leave it all there because it's
amazing to be able to walk on yeah you
don't really I don't know that they want
you to walk on it they build the path
around it oh they didn't build the path
through it like a tunnel no missed
opportunity call me next time well
update since we've been another huge
sequoia tree fell this past winter
what's happening and it fell Mike's it
they said it was from the weight of this
of the snow you know we had a lot of
snow last winter it fell not only did it
fall it fell diagonally across the two
that you you and I saw I was like we're
starting they're like a Lincoln Log
situation yeah they're stacking up
they're building themselves the largest
cabin so we are we are so that whole
part
closed down you can't walk over there
except for the fact that everybody still
walks over there and climbs on all of it
so we're climbing on like these three
sequoia trees that are basically stacked
on each other I mean when it's laying on
its side it's still like eight feet tall
yeah they're big
so you having to climb up on this thing
so I'm I'm climbing up there and Lily
and Lincoln are in front of me at this
point and I just see Lily who stands as
I'm climbing up she's standing looking
down she's like oh no oh no I and
there's no way I can't believe this and
she's staring down she says my phone
fell out of my pants she was wearing she
was wearing some sweatpants not unlike
the the ones that Keiko got from
mythical dot-com dude you gotta be
careful hiking and doing activities with
with your electronics in us in a pocket
of a sweat pant right and of course I'm
immediately like wanting to go into dad
lecture mode but then I thought you know
what this is this is the moment that
heroes are made of because she looked
down and I get up there and III way
before I even saw where the where the
phone was or whatever I was just okay it
fell down there we'll go get it
I'll get it come Pegasus Holly the hero
but then I got up there and I looked and
it had fallen it it bounced Plinko style
in between the stack of three sequoia
trees down into a hole and the hole was
no I could I could put my I could put my
head and one arm through it like it was
about that big around that's that's all
that was how far were you from the hole
you had to go down into it I had so I
crawled down was like listen let's not
panic
she was like dad and went in that hole
it's like quite like 700 bones in there
there's something there's something
about I just have this belief
whenever you're losing something it's
like if you believe that you can find it
it drastically increases the chances
that you will find it like because if
you don't actually believe you could
find it but you still look it's really
you're just kind of half-assed looking
you know like subconsciously you know
you're just going through the motions
just to say you did
yeah and I believe this this is one of
my deeply held beliefs are at its how
many deeply held beliefs do you probably
want this is one of them probably
probably this and like that layering is
good
when in doubt layer out there's not a
lot yeah as my main once so I get down
on my belly I I crawl down over the
first tree and then lay down on the
second tree the older tree that had
fallen and then I I look in this hole
and then when I look in the hole and I'm
sure I'm holding on to my phone putting
it all the way into the hole with the
flashlight aren't risky Billy and I'm
looking down I'm like I could freakin I
had a vise grip on this thing the
shakiest man in the world is holding his
phone after a phone oh I'm like a phone
hole yeah and I'm like I cannot lose my
phone that would that would make me
really angry I so far I just find this
amusing and a good occasion just a
lecture my daughter when it's over yep
and I look down in there and it splits
into two holes oh gosh and there's
sawdust and sprinkles and shards and all
types of sequoia carnage down in there
sawdust so somebody was trying to cut a
hole through them I know I just think
the more people walked on it the more
debris went down in the hog and Lily
I said Lily you go down she goes down
below the second set and she's I can
hear her but I can't see her and we're
at opposite ends are like different
accesses to this hole and I'm thinking
if these things shift we're gonna get
crushed by frickin Sequoia the largest
thing on the planet is gonna gonna smush
me and my dog it'll be worth it though
but we got to find this phone because
that's all that matters did you ever say
I will find it I will find you
did you ever say that
no I didn't say anything because you
believed it so deeply though I thought
maybe you would have done that okay
so I'm looking down in there I'm pulling
debris out and I'm like if it went to
this hole to the right you're never
seeing it again but there's a hole to
the left it sounds like it's closer to
you and then Lily's like I can
she starts crawling in there and I'm
getting really nervous that she's gonna
get crushed well they haven't shifted
yet I don't think that a couple of
people on them is gonna cause him to
[ __ ] at some point everything shifts man
yeah what are the chances though it's
worth it and your f---ing you need your
phone you got your contacts in there
Lily had been in kind of a grumpy mood
before there's you know teenager you
know you chalk it up to that teenagers
and big trees yeah I got it and I'm like
what you got it she's like I got it and
it's like I stood up she comes out from
under these sequoia trees she she's like
I have it I have it and she was it was
like it was so worth it yeah like that's
the key to making teenagers happy takes
up and they love and make him find it
let him have an ear phone death
experience
she was exasperated I mean she rode this
emotional wave for the next 17 minutes
it was amazing I even vlog about it I
miss that I had I didn't post anywhere
oh okay I'll post it on the video
version of this
okay so Lily just found her phone let me
see it prove that you got it so so we
were walking up here where this fine
young man is don't drop your phone you
see how you got your phone in your hand
don't drop it because it will go down
into that hole which is underneath a
fallen sequoia tree giant sequoia
and then you're gonna have to get down
and look for it oh my gosh I can't
believe she found it I was like I was I
was so relieved it's like it feels so
good to find something you know that
time that like we went boating and then
Chris through his like some who threw
the keys and they went in the water and
then we were he was I was like you can
find him and he and he waited out to the
water I recall it you threw the keys
yeah and they went low and they hit the
side of the boat and drug directly into
the lake and without hesitation did away
without hesitation like Chris dove down
and came up with the keys which never
crazy never happens and I dropped keys
in a lake it's you they're always lost I
think that's the root of my faith when
the Bolivian you can find so Chris that
yeah Chris performed the bedrock of my
faith in finding things and that's why I
found that skittle on on el tap so
quickly here it is right cuz I believed
I could find it I think he found it
because you were closest to it but I
mean I leave I could find it and I did
find it so there's not really any
arguing that I found it very quickly you
did 1600 Eminem's I found the skittle in
20 seconds belief man beautiful are
murmur make that heaviest sword like
punching underwater
you never can hit what you're aiming for
I don't think he says Amy there it is
these 4841 no white boys no some John
nothing like Lily knows I'm John Mayer -
yeah well good man it felt good to be in
the outdoors finding a phone maintaining
a lifeline I'm proud of but but
teetering on the edge of being isolated
from from an electronic well ironically
your entire I will say I must point out
that your entire story about camping and
being an outdoor centers around you
recovering an electronic device
yeah it does doesn't it which i think is
a great lead-in to I just didn't go
camping at all I just found the
electronic device and enjoyed it for the
for the weekend we'll talk about that
but first we do want to let you know
that we got some new designs that just
dropped mythical tackle Tom I mean we
got I don't know there's like seven new
t-shirt designs this is this the largest
drop ever we're gonna say no it's not
the largest drop ever but it is amongst
the largest drops ever seven new shirts
that ironically were not wearing right
now because they're too awesome to wear
on a podcast I don't think we have them
yet check out everything at mythical
calm because rep your boys feel good so
you can feel good knowing that what
you're wearing makes makes our lives
possible it sends us on trips camping
yeah
gas money yeah but then you're
responsible I mean if you are if you are
a wasteful wasteful dude your daughter
drops her phone you're like screw it
we'll get another one you know but you
know you didn't say that you said I got
a B I've got to be a good steward I'm
gonna find this phone even if it means
sacrificing the lives of me and my
family
I'm gonna find this phone because I'm a
responsible frugal man I was not the
hero cuz she found the phone yes you
know it was your deeply held belief that
led her to find the phone because she
had given up I was obvious in the tone
of her voice in the vlog yes you didn't
see yeah
mythical calm check it out okay Rhett
let us have this VR thing you didn't
tell me you were getting this this is
what it was a spur one woman it was it
was impulse but in which I haven't done
in a while watching Delayer since we're
warming actually in shelter it the we're
actually an air-conditioned shelter
right now you could be naked and be
comfortable in this particular room
I so this is how this happened I was
listening to a podcast and the the guy
who I think he's like a video game guy I
don't lie can't remember his name
who's currently heading up or at least
intimately involved with this oculus
quest program I this is how out of the
loop I am when it comes to this stuff I
didn't even know this thing existed it's
been out since the spring okay and if
you're any sort of follower of this type
of thing you already knew this but I'll
hold it up for you link hold it up for
me okay so it it basically looks like is
it an oculus this is hostess there are
no courts so it's a true standalone
system which it's not the only
standalone system but it is the best
standalone system as far as I can tell
based on what the research that I've
done because most of the reviews said
that for the uninitiated if you were
unless you were playing a game on this
and then playing it side by side with
something on the rift which uses you
know PC power you wouldn't really know
oh really the difference it's not like
there's like a latency issue or anything
like that and some of the things that
plagued VR now the resolution I think is
a little bit lower but depending on what
the game that you're playing the
resolution you quickly adjust you
quickly adjust to you know the
resolution which is you know not great
but it doesn't get better in the future
but it's more than adequate so he's
talking about this thing and and by the
way I see it that you're smelling that I
this is a washable guard that I got that
good you change out because you know my
got my kids faces going in this thing
yeah kids watched it my kids stick their
faces in somebody oh so this actually
this cover was just installed this week
so Shepherd has worn this a little bit
and I've worn it a little bit but that's
it
but just like once or twice so I don't
know exactly what I don't know what over
you know
came over me in order to make this
purchase but he was just talking about
it and it just hit me when they began
talking about this is really a turning
point for VR now that the systems are
standalone and you don't need a PC or a
console you could wear that on a bus it
felt like a prescription for me it was
like oh this is a turning point for you
Rhett this is when you this is when you
a guy who doesn't want to have a PC at
home and hook it all up and have wires
and we don't even have a place for that
yeah this is when you can get into this
game because you you you you've been
wishing you are on the inside for a
while I just like feeling like I'm on
the cutting edge man even though I'm not
as is evidenced by the fact that I
didn't even know that this existed
I don't like go to CES and stuff like
that but I just like the idea feeling
like one of my deeply held beliefs is
the idea of feeling like I'm on the
cutting edge okay how quickly did you
get it because you want to be you want
to say today really welcome to America
man a 20-19 you got it the same day I
ordered the city I was gonna say on
Amazon we're off and it came the same
freaking day like it's such a reward for
an impulse buyer where you can get
something delivered to your door the day
you make a decision to buy it they know
you were gonna order it or something I
just think the date was he out there
just waiting for his ding ding I don't
know how the ding dings work but I just
know I got it that I got another Friday
night so and then everything else
stopped this is the Friday night that I
was camping yeah put that it put that in
perspective so to give you an idea of
how this all went down now I've got some
VR experience having played on good
mythical more along with you and because
I I feel like you're getting distracted
I can't think about two things at once
so didn't listen don't just pay
attention I'll hold this over here I
feel like every previous experience now
the experience we had at Sundance a
couple years ago where we went into this
we did that we did the VR and we were
like walking on the plank and like we
were working with each other all body
haptics that was pretty amazing and we
were we weren't doing it for it we were
kind of thinking about the fact that
these people were watching us and so
we're still trying to play it up like we
do but obviously we would do it on good
mythical more I know that I'm on a show
so I never forget that I'm on a show and
so my brain is focused in two different
places inside the the headset and the
world that is being broadcast to me but
also the world that is being broadcast
to you you know you're being watched and
so it changes the experience and I
didn't really have a mind-blowing
experience it didn't feel like a pivotal
thing for me because I haven't you know
we've got a dancer it more it and more
okay we have an oculus rift here have I
ever said hey I'm coming in for the
weekend to play it no have I ever asked
anybody here can I get on the rift No
so why would I buy something to have it
the house because I can have it at the
house because I can make it my there's
no wild thing now so what what does it
do do you remember what does it do I
mean what do you know we wanna you know
what it does so do you remember I know
did you get a Nintendo right when they
came out I got one for Christmas when
they were selling them with the power
pads but I did not get the power pad I
have to think it was around that same
time I don't remember not having one
well I guess it when everyone was
talking about I think Nintendo came out
in 87 and I don't know if it was
Christmas of 87 or 88 when we'd like i
think abou east creek got word I think
it was 86 86 okay so the next year might
so must been Christmas 87 cuz I there's
no way that we were that on top of the
tree now no but so by the time Nintendo
was being sold at brindle's it's like
when my parents were in the game and we
had an inn we had an Atari and I played
Atari yeah sure I played some yeah but I
specifically remember sitting down and
playing Super Mario Brothers in 1987
I'm feeling like something had shifted
that my life was going to be different
and I remember going to bed that night
and thinking about Super Mario Brothers
like it was the line between reality and
dreams had been disintegrated do you
know what I'm saying it was like it's
interesting from from I I remember
getting that feeling when I first got
cable and I got I watched Nickelodeon
like I couldn't stop thinking about what
else I was doing get to watch on
Nickelodeon but I didn't have that
reacting to take videogames well you
know oddly programming just for me
yeah it's always on you know just I'm
missing something it's difficult to
emphasize just how different it felt and
how big of a leap it felt like now that
was pretty much that was the biggest
leap for me and then I never got Super
Nintendo we got a Sega Genesis around
like a year later or whatever those are
really the only two gaming systems that
I ever had I didn't out my life changed
and I got busy with sports and stuff and
and then we just never ended up having
consoles I just wasn't a videogames guy
and of course I haven't been as an adult
but putting this on and I was playing
the game that the two games that I
downloaded were beat Sabre which is one
that everybody says you got to have you
got to have it it's an essential game on
the on the quest which is essentially
its revolution with a lightsaber you're
basically sitting there with two sabers
yes and you're chopping the sabers
chopping these blocks a red and blue
block but depending on which side it's
on to a beat and you're doing in all
different ways and you're dodging things
or whatever pretty pretty awesome but I
also downloaded a game called super hot
now it sounds like it might be a little
racy it's not a little slinky dinky I
has nothing to do with Dinky's or
slinkys it is it's a game that's been
out for a while a console it's been on
consoles I guess it's been on PCs as
well but essentially it is a
first-person shooter game where you are
your
motion determines the speed at which
time moves so if you get if you stand
still
you're not moving time stand still and
in every level there's an array of like
weapons in front of you that that are
all kinds of different things you things
you can throw are things you can shoot
and there are these completely red dudes
almost looked like they're made out of
red glass who are coming at you and
shooting things at you okay trying to
kill you and multiple ones coming at you
and you have to stop them but they'll
shoot like a bullet at you and it's
coming at you and you can see it coming
you can stop you can see where it's
going and then you can move out of the
way but you got to make sure you don't
move into another bullet or whatever so
if you freeze the bullet freezes
everything freezes time moves as fast as
you do now so it's kind of like you're
the matric you're going to experience it
in a second oh just be forewarned like
when the when time would slow down and
he would like do a back bend and and the
bullets would fly over exactly same
thing okay so I'm playing this game in
my living room and I and basically it
gives you the the opportunity to mark
off of this playing space and we like
move the I move the you know the coffee
table coffee table out of the way I made
a giant like a 10 by 12 space which is
pretty big for VR okay and right next to
a pool nope I was inside good and and so
then I'm playing this game and I'm just
having I'm having that feeling that I
haven't had since 1987 oh yeah I'm like
this changes things man were you like we
tearing up now no I probably looked like
an idiot I was in my underwear in my
living room
with a headset dodging invisible bullets
now no shirt are you talking like under
t-shirt no shirt man I don't sleep with
a shirt on boxers yeah
or briefs not briefs boxers okay boxer
briefs
possibly why do you care because this is
disturbing to me and I want to make sure
I've got it right because if there's an
opportunity for me to be less disturbed
okay there was a shirt and it wear
boxers okay so I play and then I do a
couple other things I also got a game
called
you're like dodging bullets like matrix
like you're doing a back thing and yeah
you don't know I'm not hurting I'm gonna
hurt myself you're doing Taichi
basically you're slow so you do moves
that would be a we'll see how it looks
in a second when I went I'll do it first
to demonstrate and then let you let you
get in on it I also did something called
there's a not a game but an app called
wander okay and this basically is every
single thing that has been mapped with
Google Maps on the like Google Street
View basically in the entire world you
have access to it and you can enter into
it so you can say go to my old address
and Fuquay where I used to live and
you'll be at you'll be on the street at
your old house you can see full 360 view
of because that's because the 360 camera
captured all this yeah yeah but you can
also go to like amazing locations that
they've mapped around the world I went
to the freaking island that we were
defeating when we went to castaway
island and Fiji
oh yeah in his voice activated you say
go to castaway island fiji and all of a
sudden you're on the freakin beach at
the resort that we stayed at you go to
the trail of 100 giants probably walk i
don't know is some people have mapped
this stuff and it's like user-generated
like i think you probably have to have
some sort of special application or
whatever but you can go to a remote
location and then send it into the
system i don't know how it's it's a
crowd-sourced kind of thing anyway that
was super cool but I just got all this
knock on the door you can't do that yet
so I did all this and I'm doing this by
myself I haven't my kids haven't even
done this yet cuz I'm like dad's gonna
figure this stuff out for you guys which
is code for this is my toy yeah and also
yeah and I also did say that I was like
this is this is it going in my room
because I want it to be cared for and
you can use it at my discretion oh yeah
also I don't want the kids to like get
addicted because case in point
so I put the thing on lock and the only
thing that so there's a there's a first
it's called first steps and it's
basically an orientation to how
everything works and so you've got these
controllers you know that have a few few
functions on them like there's a grip
and there's a trigger and there's this
thing and basically they replicate
pointing and gripping all kinds of hand
motions with this simple controller and
in the orientation you're in this room
just first of all just when the room in
the world is sort of generated around
you and then like this like desk comes
up in front of you and there's all these
things on it and you pick these things
up and it's showing you how to interact
with things by telling you what buttons
to press and there's like a rocket thing
that you pull a string and then it flies
way and then you actually there's a
drone like inside the orientation and
you're controlling it with a fake
controller that you're holding but
you're good you're holding a controller
in VR
controlling a thing but you're just
using it so it's pretty mind-blowing
so I the best way to introduce somebody
to it which I'm gonna skip past that for
you because it takes too long you've
also been in VR before is to use this
program this first step so I I put the
headset on like kind of like brain
mapping yeah you're get your you're
adjusting to how you're going to
interact with this world so put the
thing on lock he's going through and
he's doing these different little
experiments and then he's standing there
in the middle of the living room he says
dad because you feel like you have to
talk louder because the people are
outside of the world you know dad
this is air dad this is the best thing
that has ever happened to me really and
I felt like I that made me a proud dad
I'd sent my son into VR and he realized
that that's where all his dreams come
true he literally felt like it well it
was the best thing that ever happened to
me that's what reminded me of that
Nintendo moment I was like this is his
Nintendo moment
because he's he's a kid that he's a kid
in 2019 in LA in a family that can
afford to get him stuff like an Xbox
this kid you can't blow his mind
mm-hmm you can't blow his mind he's a
cynical teenager yet blew his mind it
blew his mind and of course if he took
this thing 200 giants and dropped it in
a hole and it found found it that would
be even better we might have to arrange
that if he begins to take it for granted
I'll definitely do that same thing with
Shepherd shepherd was had an incredible
time playing this thing so what I'll do
it is mind blowing and you never get a
second chance to have that feeling that
VR virginity right which is you're
technically not a virgin right no it's
like you've experimented a little bit
but you know it you didn't know what you
were doing they were young right I mean
now you need practice you're gonna get
the real thing
let's so what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to set up I'm gonna get into super hot
you're gonna in and then I'm gonna stand
up and I'm gonna do just a little bit
and then I'm gonna get out of it you're
gonna have to come over here because
I've got the Guardian kind of sub down
the side all right but but maybe maybe
there's still you know there's still
some part in the euphemism there's a
little cherry to pop I don't know maybe
there's this is still gonna be a
formative experience okay all right
avoid that language okay so are you are
you gonna be whispering or yelling
change Guardian I'm gonna put them I'm
gonna make sure the mic is still near
you but you got to speak up it captures
better than you think okay
okay now of course none of us can see
what's happening so I'm that yeah so you
can get
okay I'm gonna stand up what are you
doing
loosening everything you know getting
stretched up okay you just waggling your
hips a little bit now that I've
completely beat this game I can go into
it any there's all these disks I can put
them in different computers to access
different levels okay now after oh it's
a freaking light there man
I have to reach up here and grab this
you couldn't bust a light
yeah you've lost touch total contact
with the real world man it's not healthy
you're not really having to move that
much yeah well it gets very it gets a
lot more complicated as it gives kisses
to the game you got to start doing
squats and now warrior pose and stuff
okay so here's what I'm gonna do link
I'm gonna give this to you and it's
gonna be great there is a black ball in
front of you when you're gonna have this
on and you're gonna reach down you're
gonna grab that and that will start the
action okay okay sustain exactly where I
was standing
I'm gonna leave my glasses on over my
glasses oh yeah there's a I'm in a white
room okay here you go so here's the left
hand that's looking yep
and right hand I got I got floaty hands
and then okay up you still pleased till
you see those guys oh yeah it's coming
at me so this dude up here shot me do
you have a gun no I have a hand pick up
a guy oh he hit me in the shoulder and I
died this is what I look like am i
living alright so then it's riveting oh
this guy shot me oh yeah boom boom
buckshot
what what did I just not go over die Oh
glad you got camo on I just I just threw
i just threw the gun at a guy and it
killed him right okay boom boom boom
boom boom you don't have to say boom I'm
frozen nobody's moving I killed that guy
the sound effects are really good oh I
just dodged a bullet I grabbed a gun and
I shot him and he just died
OHRP okay alright okay we can do this
more later all right put the controls
down Oh Oh my heart rate is freaking
through the roof man I don't one thing I
got to say is it's just a white room of
red guys there's not a lot of graphics
happening like turbo graphics 16 just
blows out Wow I'll show you who even
just the beginning my whole body was
tense it you can justify this as a
workout oh he's like my core was engaged
well I felt like I was in a squatting
position for most of the time and I
learned how to kill people
so like I'm like they're not really
people I'm comfortable killing slight
robots red robots okay oh so that was
that was just a little taste now one of
the things that happened to me after
playing that game was got a stretch it
changed the way I was moving I was
literally eating cereal for breakfast
you tell my the real world now yeah I
was eating cereal for breakfast and I
found myself getting ready to take a
bite and then stopping taking a bite and
looking around and seeing if any red men
were coming after me and I was like and
then I would eat this thought I could I
can make everyone else slow down by by
stopping it's kind of like the way that
your brain adapts because you you're the
whole deal
is your brain everything in your your
brain is telling you that you are here
this is how the world is now the world
this is your world and so you can you
could train there's so many different
applications for I'm sure people are
already doing this but in the way that
in just a couple of sessions of playing
that game I changed my actual
interaction in the real world there was
something I was struggling with you
could definitely train somebody to like
address some kind of problem in that
like a like a surgeon or an EMT
simulator would you buy it like a super
realistic EMT simulator because it you
know there probably is such a thing you
don't want to you don't want to roll up
on an accident and then be totally
paralyzed you know and they when my mom
was EMT certified I you know I was in
middle school and I'd stroll I'd stroll
through the room where they were getting
their training and they'd be they'd be
showing some graphic images right yeah
nasty well okay so this is a step
further you're right that the graphics
that you saw this is like one of the
most simple simple graphic games that
there is now there's other games that
are much more vivid and lots of
different colors and you know cool
gameplay though one of the things I also
did with this was because I heard they
got talking about he's like you know not
everybody has a great home theater but
this can basically replicate a home
theater so there's actually I've got
Netflix on here and so you are in I
gotta show it to you man can you just
want to put it on and see what Netflix
like yeah yeah I want to see I also want
to eat cereal in VR if that's when you
were referring to that earlier I got
excited but I totally know what you're
talking about as you're getting ready
yet that your brain starts to think
things in the real world work that way
like there's many times when I'm looking
it's like a brochure or something with
fine print and I will find myself
reaching down to then zoom in on it you
know like oh let me make that bigger
and at least the thought will cross my
mind and then I'll realize oh no this is
okay comes that that can't happen
come sit down in my living room talk
about disappointment on a brochure so
you're telling me welcome to my living
room
Wow okay so Oh
dude you'd live in a ski lodge faulted
ceilings got a big chandelier that is a
freaking huge strain my television
that's the biggest dude you didn't tell
me you had such a big television yeah in
it I love how your mantelpiece has the
word Netflix burned in it like what what
asshat would burn the word Netflix into
his mantelpiece in his ski lodge home
nice yeah yeah you got a loft up there
yeah I'm on it
walk around that's me that's my body I'm
on a cat I'm actually sitting no I'm
actually I'm actually sitting behind the
couch when I like down okay and then so
I'm is a screen here but then it's just
the rest of the I'm just in a lodge I
mean it's like where would you be if you
were watching Netflix where would you
actually be what I when I'm watching
shows I tend to just watch the show I
don't look around my room yeah don't
look around just watch the show all
right take it off before you I don't
want to take it off I want to be in your
life out of my line I'm watching the
screen saver of Netflix and it's pretty
awesome
get out of my Lodge okay so I I don't
think I don't think that no no it's okay
lemon you would want to keep
well not in 2019 not now now I will say
that I watched watched that show mine
hunter okay oh gosh almost fell I
watched a full episode of that in --see
you can't even sit in a chair in the
real world anymore
inside that and I got to say that there
it
this is where the resolution becomes
frustrating because if I were to just
take the headset off and watch on my
television or on my phone the resolution
would be significantly higher but that's
just a matter of time before they get
that straightened out but I do have I do
have a few critiques oculus people if
you're watching it's too heavy because
it's a standalone thing well first of
all in all of the weight is in front of
your eyes there's potentially this is a
good thing because they can put weight
on top of your head well again yeah so
it feels like it might limit your
there's to a two-hour battery life which
is not a lot for something but now you
can just plug it in it's got a pretty
long cable so you can kind of stay
tethered if you want to have it being
powered as you're playing if you're
doing that you might as well plug it
into a PC right but then you hear you're
just defeating the whole purpose of the
thing but also the rift has a lot less
weight because you're not using all the
computing power is offloaded to an
actual computer where this is basically
like having a cell phone in your face
you know so I feel like they could have
offloaded some of the way to like a
different place like you're saying like
if it was a little I don't know I'm sure
that I'm not telling you anything you
don't you didn't try probably but if
there was like exit for him some battery
or the CPU power was offloaded to
another spot on your head to make it a
more even thing like it was a little bit
more helmet see I think the playability
and the comfort ability if that's a word
would have gone up probably safer if it
was a helmet - but I so I feel like a
nut listen again it sound like a couple
of old guys talking about something
that's been around for a long time
because that is exactly what's happening
right now but I think that it's just hit
me what this is going to turn into you
know obviously what's the few times I've
read and watched ready player one so
everybody knows that there's what that
whole dystopian future looks like and
people are living their lives in VR you
definitely begin to understand how when
they work out the ergonomics of this
thing
and they get the physicality right and
they continue to enhance the haptic
quality of this it gets to a place where
you could definitely get lost in this
world now one of the things I didn't
show you is that this thing one of the
way that this thing works is there's
four cameras in it so you think I was
that was wondering if there's no camera
so when you're just walking around with
this thing it replicates your world and
I could just walk around with this thing
on really it's it's black and white kind
of grainy representation of the world so
I could sit here and see you and
everything is exactly where it needs to
be based on these four cameras yeah so
the moment that they get to a place
where you don't look like an asshat
wearing this thing which that that I
don't know know when that's going to
happen but if they might as well just go
all the way and put a crack in the
middle of it so again I believe that
this is necessarily going to require
some offloading of the CPU and the
battery power somewhere else I don't
we're not gonna we're not gonna get to a
place unless technology changes
significantly where battery power and
CPU power capable of creating the types
of graphic experiences that would
replicate actual reality can be housed
in a very small space the size of
glasses I mean maybe eventually but
there's there's limitations to computing
that are like to do have to do with
physics you can't just keep getting
smaller and smaller smaller they're
already getting close to reaching the
end of Moore's law with how small that
can make a processor so given that
there's some limitations that they're
gonna run up on we're probably gonna get
to a place where you're offloading the
CPU and battery power into some other
part of your body where it's like on
your shoulders or your back but we're in
your mouth or just yeah you just it's
just like a Snickers bar I don't know
why you put it in your mouth like a
mouth guard but the other thing that's
happening is in fact just today when I
when I was looking up some stuff about
the latest in VR technology there's a
company that has developed the second
skin that is like it's gonna represent a
true touch like experience where they
can make a they'll be able to soon make
a glove
the second skin that some Swiss company
or somebody developed where when you
touch something it will give you
feedback that feels exactly like touch
sort of like the haptic glove dream that
we've always had now yeah so when I grab
that black ball or that you'll feel it
firearm yeah you can you use the haptic
response well and a thing that they've
actually already rolled out they haven't
rolled it out for everyone on the quest
but they just introduced it recently but
they're rolling it out next year is hand
tracking so you can set the controllers
down you could play games with just your
hands and it's using the four cameras to
track your hands apparently that's
coming Wow so you combine really awesome
hand tracking with really awesome
haptics you get the situation so that
you you basically all you need on your
face is a visual interface that's all
you need so if we could get to a place
where it kind of looks like sunglasses
mm-hmm and then you've got stark the
other stuff on your back or whatever at
that point you can operate on people
you're getting to a place where
switching between AR and VR becomes this
just like effortless thing so the AR the
augmented reality where you're gonna be
able to be given information about
everything that you're seeing to have
your experience enhance Robocop that
just feels like I mean that's already
happening some places people use their
phones or whatever but that's gonna be
something that everyone who has one of
these contraptions will have and then
the moment you start kind of getting
annoyed with the real world you'll voice
activate to go into VR and you'll be in
to be so comfortable that you will
literally be able to get lost in it
because you won't be stopping to think
about oh my face hurts which is what
happens with this thing hi yeah I gotta
just about it's on the back of my head
when that goes away and you're not
worried about battery power you can do
this for long periods of time it's gonna
change society very significantly
everywhere you go will be like a tourist
attraction because there'll be a filter
that will turn off all the ads which
will inevitably be on everything hold
this microphone you can buy it now and
it'll be delivered tonight and here's
the specs on it and this table well you
can buy what
we'll just like this from Target
you know you've you you block all of
that stuff and then you turn on fun
facts and augmented yeah talking head
well what was the name of that show
where they introduced that pop-up TV
thing the very first show to do that or
just let you be watching like something
along h1 the pop-up TV pop-up video
pop-up video which is the way life the
way that video games work currently
where there's like a user name above
somebody's head and details about them
we would we will get to a place where
that's happening with people that you're
just interacting with and then I don't
know it's just the potential I'm not
saying anything that thousand science
fiction books haven't already written
about but but now you experience because
I have understood it personally and
experienced it it hit me like whoa okay
this could be problematic for society
like this is something that we're going
to have to address I mean just think
about it like you you know we're already
we're already in some societies are
moving to a place we're like kids are
you know like teenagers and and young
adults are not they're not dating
they're not having sex
you've got populations where they're not
replacing themselves and of course we've
got a population issue but ultimately
you want this you want our species to be
active and replacing itself right and
what this is going to do is when the
haptics get good enough if you know what
I mean you're not going to need a
partner for sexual gratification that is
something that is going to be happening
in these headsets and that is going to
change society significantly and is
something that we need to be thinking
about well yeah you just made me think
about it I'm pretty distracted I'm just
saying that's gonna happen man the way
the experiences can be replicated in the
second skin and all this stuff that's
coming coming is probably not the best
word to use that's on its way I mean
every
technology is is it's been exploited for
either is pornography in military right
pornography and military explain well
I'm just saying that you got that's how
that's how things are developed you talk
about just oh oh think about space
travel the technologies will be
exploited exploited first because that's
where that's where them
that's where either the money is like
all this money funneled in the military
is how like ok VR is going to be
advanced because for for militaristic
purposes and then it's gonna be co-opted
for pornographic purpose right but then
it's gonna make its way into mainstream
society I completely agree with you what
I'm specifically saying is that in the
way that phones and cell phone use has
already contributed to people being kind
of isolated in one sense very connected
but also lonely and ISIL and happy the
moment you can replicate the most
intimate human experiences with
technology is the moment in which those
human intimate experiences will be
replaced with technology and and and so
that's all I'm saying there'll be a
movement of there'll be a there'll be a
retro realness movement where it's like
you know it the silver lining is it's an
opportunity to draw into sharp focus
what really matters you know what just
to have a great experience be that
pleasurable or a learning experience or
just something unforgettable like an
amazing hike through VR or something
like that yeah there's gonna be an
entire movement of yes but we've
forgotten you can you can be made to
feel really good but there's there's
something you can't match the reward of
vulnerability with another person but
and the dance of that will be making
those arguments towards young people who
don't want to hear them and but the UH
the other let me cent tell it to my tell
it to my relational BOTS yeah the only
purpose
honorable to me the other alarming thing
that I think this represents is that
because the experience is by design by
design are to your liking right yeah
their designs to be your the center of
the universe hater to you yeah
that is not how life works that's that's
the that is the that sum up of the
danger so I think if you you become the
center of the you but if you are
constantly in this world in which
everything is catered to you and so when
you have your experiences in this
however intimate those experiences might
be never leave it everything is exactly
the way that you want it the person is
behaving exactly the way that you want
doing exactly what you want your wish is
my command you are basically a slave is
what would be in here now you're trying
to take that experience and map it on to
an actual interaction with another human
that has its own interests and does not
care about your interest to the way that
you do we're going we have to think
about this like from an eye and listen
I'm just a guy who makes internet videos
but and I'm sure people are already
talking about this but it's just hit me
it'll sell yourself short you're also an
impulse buyer just having worn this
thing and owned it for like a month the
potential it's like I've got this very
scary thing now thankfully and you're
hooking it up to your children and well
you know what and to speak to speak to
that interestingly and I think I just
got lucky with this my kids are lock
lock is just busy
I mean he's busy with school and
basketball he hasn't asked me to play on
this thing probably like once in the
past month after after his initial
interaction and Shepard has asked me a
few more times because he's younger he's
got more time he he uses screens more
often but because I've kind of got it in
the room and I've got it kind of sealed
away they can't just go get it whenever
they want to the amount of actual time
that
they've spending this is very minimal
what about you though
I got you no I got it I had that weekend
and it was a kind of a special weekend
because we didn't anything else going on
and I wasn't there and then I was in the
great outdoor a few weeks have passed
since that point and I'd say I'm not
over it every time I get in it I'm like
man this is so cool I got to get more
games and I've gotten a couple of more
games but I am there's like a cool
puzzle game which reminded me of the
escape room is basically you're in an
escape room situation but you're in a
awesome you're like in an abandon like
nuclear facility and you're walking all
around and like you're playing with
things and trying to unlock codes and
stuff very similar to like in a skate
room in Florida but better because
you're in your underwear and your
underwear but I act but no thankfully I
don't have an addictive personality when
it comes to stuff like this and I don't
think my kids do so but it's just
hitting me that if I wasn't so busy if I
didn't have so many other things to
distract me you could just sit in this
thing all day mm-hmm it's gonna happen
it's probably already happening can I
borrow it
now you can rent it you can release it
is this your baby Rick babe a-one two
three four
check baby you know I'd be a racket I
have another wreck but I'm gonna go I'll
save that for later yes this is my
racket if you want there all that danger
again this is not a sponsor we haven't
maybe we can work it out in the out in
the future let's just think cause I got
the there's 399 399 for everything that
you need it's console ish pricing uh and
I got a say for somebody who's not an
aficionado but it was just kind of like
a little bit familiar with it it was the
it was the doorway from me man it's it
was the gate it's the gateway into VR I
highly recommend it and yeah it's the
wreck get you one of these things get
lost in the world see the potential for
the doom of the human species
it cost me $400 less to gain access to
the trail of 100 yeah but you can't just
be at home getting ready to go to bed
and think I'd like to go to Idaho
I can Idaho huh
I can go to Idaho hashtag your bits go
to any state you want let us know how
alarmed you are we'll talk at you next
week to watch more ear biscuits click on
the playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]